hello and welcome to this video like
chess for good so Italian game again and
why is this getting popular okay he's
playing them the evans at least five so
let's see i think i usually play with c
6 cm and probably will do some normally
they play Queen a4 at some point and
John he didn't do that maybe I shouldn't
have let c 6 feet but ok inside hind
sight is 2020 hmm so what to do night is
pretty dangerous-looking but first of
all I have to let's get the roof into
the game you're playing Knight to f3
probably anyway
I want to go look ad a potentially drop
back to see aid
why it's taking a while it's in light to
to f3 a very natural move preparing at
five yeah maybe he's trying for
something else interesting but I don't
mind to trade my off-site museum
absolutely not and I can take afore here
Bishop gee I can take h7 at then don't
like that is probably threatening me
five here yeah interesting okay I don't
want to take on c4 thats it's giving him
too much I would assume that he five
move is annoying
okay Abby five is an option of pushing
it back okay let's do it
93a still se5
he will just go night III and then I
don't really have a great move
I will thinking Bishop c5 but yeah maybe
he 595 fine very quickly played
just try to irritate him here maybe
still be five to be honest
young so g6 I take with the pony also
has rook f3 which is looking bloody
dangerous
g6 Kim f5
if I have to maybe I can actually play
Bishop c4 f5 bishops you form that might
not be an immediate mate
yeah so you just yell queen some Queen
to h6 hand hits Jack made my idea would
be rocked the eighth maybe for rookie 2
or t3 get get some counter play and it
can take this six ok I can take here
it's probably not not so easy for him
may I can fight for a draw here still
unfortunately yeah this is strong I just
spotted it
it's um it's really strong I don't have
a movie I don't believe it time morning
maybe I can play Queen takes f6 I can
take with the Queen on f6 if things go
wrong they go really wrong amazing check
check check check check so he decided to
try its luck on time grah alpha jet game
drive okay it takes a tune that's nice
could have win on one on time okay whoa
i plated we're a very well jam night
dear three looks totally normal and this
somehow doesn't feel very logical with
the night on if I had I already Knight
takes e4 already is wrong the NGA goes
with this yeah this is interesting but
who's finding this in blitz cam I felt
this looks totally normal that I
exchanged my oxide night but here also
yeah maybe I should take before I mean I
saw this of course but I didn't like
that I thought he teach at age seven but
if I'm not in trouble here maybe this is
the way to go engine gives me a slight
edge here yeah and justifiably so if you
move so look I have Bishop c5 so this
was the way to tackle to handle this Kim
yeah I'm in trouble maybe GTX I don't
know and then I can at least fight but
yet this rookie ate all of a sudden walk
t1 also was interesting now check now he
has to keep the Queen's Own after the
can trade i think i have very good were
drawing chances my king is active and
very likely i'm getting a pot and cook
ending I all know that I'm going to
check this was just there so I had some
chances at the beginning of this but
after that I was in trouble really well
played by my opponent okay thanks for
watching